mindfulness is one of the big ideas
that's come in from Asia that's had a
huge impact on America and basically the
idea of mindfulness as it's practiced in
America is one of teaching one to accept
one's feelings to if one feels anger or
jealousy just sort of read distance
oneself from it and the goal is to allow
one to move to the day not being so
taken up by these negative emotions that
seems very powerful but of course the
danger of such an approach is that it's
really teaching us not to make any
fundamental changes in our life it's
simply teaching us to accept and not be
so bothered by things as they occur now
Chinese philosophers will on the
contrary push strongly that no you
actually don't want to be too
comfortable with the world as it is or
with interactions as they are or are
things you're doing as they currently
are being done they would say oh no you
should actually be training yourself to
respond in ways that can actually affect
situations for the better
alter your relationships but really
alter the situation's you're in and I
would even add mindfulness as it was
originally practiced was actually much
closer to this idea and what's really in
America that it's been turned into a
kind of acceptance mantra whereas a lot
of the Asian philosophies and this is
certainly true of China as well the
focus really is on altering changing
changing yourself changing interactions
changing the world within which we exist
we tend to love the idea of nature and
we tend to think that our problem is
humans is that we've become too
artificial and that we should return to
nature in some way either return to
nature as it exists outside of us so
means taking a nice walk in the park on
a weekend for example or returning to
our nature within ourselves and so to
really stick to who we are who we
fundamentally are or a basic nature that
were born where things were gifted at
doing and really focus on who we
naturally are meant to be shoes I would
argue that both of these visions of
nature are actually potentially
dangerous
first of all let's begin with the self
this self sure we're born with lots of
things but shows it would say we're born
with a lot of messy things we're born
with desires dispositions faculties and
we're all kind of equally born with a
bunch of messy stuff and the focus
shouldn't be on sticking or returning or
embracing that stuff with which we're
born the goal is actually to change
yourself transform yourself as Confucius
will say overcome this self meaning this
messy self and train yourself to be
something better than you were at birth
and shouldn't it would even make the
same point with the larger natural world
around us pointing out that actually
most of what we think of as natural is
already quite artificial there's nothing
natural about a part this is an
artificial attempt by humans to create a
seemingly natural space to which
shouldn'ta would respond that's a
wonderful thing to do but let's be aware
that we've constructed it and therefore
asked the question with a park for
example just as we would ask for
ourselves have we done a good job of
constructing this nature have we done a
good job of working with this world that
we're born into and the stuff that we
are born with so his question would
always be don't return to nature um it's
how you work with things that we're born
into and how you work with the stuff
that we were born with the danger of
thinking that nature is good is that it
restrains us so I'll give a very typical
example um we often like to think that
the way to become a good person is to
look within find one's true self
there's sort of a natural self that we
have and once you found that self that
natural thing that you are the goal is
to be sincere and authentic to that true
self so if we stick to what we naturally
are meant to be the gifts that were
naturally endowed with that's how we can
be a sincere authentic person now a lot
of our Chinese philosophers would say
that sounds good but is a lot is on the
contrary extremely restraining and
constraining to what we could do the
fact is if we're messy creatures as many
of them would say
what we perhaps are in our daily lives
are simply people whose emotions are
being pulled out all the time by people
we encounter interactions we have and
over time those responses fall into kind
of rats and patterns that can just be
repeated endlessly so someone does
something it makes me angry and not even
because of what they immediately did but
because for some reason it brings back
say you know someone from my childhood
yelling at me and I just have a
patterned response to a certain action
being done in a certain way bias by
anyone that brings out a certain
response so if they're on to something
in this and I might add lots of
psychological experiments show that they
really are then what that means if you
try to look within and find your true
self this thing you think you naturally
are what you're probably finding are
just a bunch of patterns you fall into
many of which could potentially be
dangerous for you for those around you
and if that's the goal you should be
trying to break those patterns alter
those patterns change the way you
interact in the world and if you're
simply saying I should be who I
naturally am meant to be well what
you're probably doing is simply
continuing to follow a bunch of patterns
probably destructive to yourself and
almost assuredly destructive to those
around you